Speaker 1: Hey, this is super interesting. Many
of you, I am sure, remember the things that
Donald Trump said about people who plead
the fifth, right? Do you guys remember this
Speaker 4: Fifth Amendment bar? The
mob takes over. If you're innocent,
why are you taking the Fifth Amendment, right?
Speaker 1: Why would if you if you have nothing
to hide if you're innocent, you wouldn't invoke
the Fifth Amendment against self-incrimination.
However, we have now learned that both Alex Jones,
conspiracy theorist Alex Jones and Donald Trump's
own son, Eric Trump invoked their Fifth Amendment
right hundreds of times during their testimony to
the January six Trump Riot Committee report from
Business Insider. Far right conspiracy theorist
Alex Jones pleaded the Fifth Amendment almost
100 times before the January 6th Committee. What
I thought Only guilty people did that. Alex
Jones, a far right conspiracy theorist and host
of Infowars, invoked his Fifth Amendment
right against self-incrimination almost
100 times while testifying Monday before the
House Select Committee investigating the Jan. six
Capitol riot. Jones made the revelation during his
broadcast that evening, and his remarks were first
reported by Politico. As you might recall,
Jones spoke at the Stop the Steal rally,
headlined by Trump on Jan. six. CNN reported Jones
was intricately involved in planning the event,
and The Wall Street Journal reported Jones
helped secure a $300000 donation for the
rally's costs and offered more than 50 grand
of his own money to choose his speaking slot.
Eric Trump, also invoking Eric Trump, invoked
Fifth Amendment about 500 times. Now this is
in a different probe. This is in the New
York Attorney General Probe article from
a few days ago. Eric Trump invoked the Fifth
Amendment more than 500 times. Can you imagine
when the Trump Organization EVP was deposed as
part of a civil probe into the company's asset
valuation? The second son answered only background
questions under oath and cited his constitutional
right to avoid incriminating himself. In response
to more than 500 questions over six hours,
if you only need to look to Donald Trump to
get an understanding of what it means when one
invokes the Fifth Amendment, remember
Speaker 4: her staffers taking the
Fifth Amendment? How about that and her
ringleaders? Getting immunity is now?
She has people taking the Fifth Amendment. Four
people, plus the guy who illegally did the server,
you know, he put it in the illegal server. Oh, so
they have five people taking the Fifth Amendment
like you see on the mob, right?
You see the mob takes off.
If you're innocent, why are you taking the Fifth
Amendment? Wow. Interesting question. And then
they read a whole list of charges. She's guilty on
every one of them. And then what are they say? But
that's OK. And yet other people?
Speaker 1: Yeah. So you guys get the
point by Donald Trump's own perspective, by his
own statement, pleading the fifth is an indication
of guilt. Now I have to tell you part of this
is just the cartoony and hypocritical nature
right there, pleading the fifth and Trump says you
go. The the other aspect to this is it actually is
a really important constitutional reality in the
United States that not speaking your innocence
cannot be used against you. And so the first
part is the cartoonish hypocrisy where I'm sure
if you said to Trump, Sir in 2017 or whenever you
said pleading the fifth means you're guilty, but
your son pleaded the fifth 500 times he would say,
Well, no, but he's being railroaded in a witch
hunt, so it would be different. That would be one
piece. But the other thing is they claim to be
all about the Constitution. They claim to be all
about the Bill of Rights due process and all of
these things, suggesting that pleading the fifth
is an indication of guilt. Violates all of that.
So as usual, their stated principle that they are
the primary defenders of the Constitution and the
Bill of Rights and Due Process. And then they love
this idea of if you plead the fifth, you're guilty
violates that as well. It shouldn't surprise us.
Their principles are of no importance whatsoever.
Once the principles are inconvenient to
the point that they want to get across.